on vous raconte ce soir l'histoire d'un
des pionniers du recyclage au québec
deux frères en fait de beauce qui ont
l'entreprise recyc rpm une entreprise
qui transforme le plastique en petites
passes et de plastique pour refaire des
tablettes des boîtes etc
or ils viennent de se placer sous la loi
de la protection de la faillite ça ne
fonctionne absolument pas notre système
du style reportage ans sébastien
cloutier à beauceville au coeur de la
vallée de la chaudière recyc rpm occupe
une place importante
jusqu'au 22 mai 90 personnes
travaillaient ici
mais l'entreprise vient de se placer
sous la protection de la loi des
faillites
lors de notre visite la semaine dernière
les machines fonctionner au ralenti et
les propriétaires louis et luc métivier
se préparer à les arrêter
les deux frères ont roulé leur bosse
dans l'industrie du recyclage
l'entreprise de leur grand-père ipl a
été à l'origine des premiers bacs
roulants au québec et c'est à la fin des
années 80 et qu'ils sont partis en
affaires
recyc rpm achètent des ballots de
contenants de plastique utilisé comme
celui ci les broie literie les lave les
faons puis on fait des petites billes
qui seront par la suite envoyé au moulin
on peut fabriquer des pièces de
manutention des bois on peut fabriquer
des états vers louis métivier en a gros
sur le coeur
recyc rpm vient d'investir 10 millions
de dollars pour acheter des équipements
aux technologies mais le certificat
d'autorisation de québec pour opérer a
pris plus d'un an à obtenir les dépenses
sont aussi accumulés et aujourd'hui ils
courent à la banqueroute
notre industrie est malade ici au québec
il faut repenser complètement le système
limite yviers sont les derniers d'une
longue liste de recycleur en difficulté
si on parle depuis les dix dernières
années là on au minimum 95 % de la
production de produits finis de
plastique en pet son petit but d'arrêter
ici au québec
il en a long à dire sur ce qui cloche
dans l'industrie d'abord les centres de
tri vendent leurs ballots au plus
offrant et les acheteurs sont souvent à
l'extérieur du québec en chine très
souvent là où les exigences sont moins
grandes quant à la qualité des ballots
et centres de tri veut par ailleurs
comme un shaker blais ils reçoivent un
chèque pour avoir crié sa rente au
tonnage mais personne ne vérifie la
qualité de son
il évalue que les ballots livrer chez
recyc rpm contiennent 15 à 40%
d'impuretés souvent de l'aluminium ou du
verre ce qui provoque des bris de
machinerie et coûte cher en nettoyage et
en enfouissement
nous autres ça nous coûte 2 millions 500
mille dollars par année le jeu spore
nettoyer entre nos équipements avec
notre station d'eau et nos déchets donc
c'est dur d'être rentable avec une note
de 2 millions et demi de dollars en
commençant le début de l'année de son
garçon
pierre fillion qui représente les
recycleurs de plastique a fait le saut
en apprenant que recyc rpm fermerait
peut-être à son tour vous avez un
fleuron québécois vous avez des
entrepreneurs mais qui sont à la base
tous ceux qui ont 25 ans d'expérience
derrière la cravate qui décide de lancer
la serviette
c'est quoi le message qu'on ne sait quoi
le message qu'on donne alors moi pour
moi lors ya une urgence d'agir agir
selon lui c'est aussi redistribuer
différemment les quelque 120 millions de
dollars de redevances versées
annuellement par les fabricants de
contenant et d'emballage du québec pour
financer la collecte sélective
actuellement recyc rpm ne reçoit rien
cet argent est principalement remis aux
municipalités où on en perd la trace
est-ce que c'est argent serve uniquement
et spécifiquement pour la collecte
sélective genre de pierre fillion est
catégorique les entreprises au bout de
la chaîne doivent avoir leur juste part
les recycleurs les conditionneurs c'est
là que le vrai développement durable son
père il va falloir avoir est équitable
et responsable envers tout le monde et
il va falloir réouvrir les conventions
il va falloir et établir les maillons
les plus faibles il va falloir les
renforcer sinon l'industrie québécoise
risque de continuer à appliquer du nez
gens du milieu et fonctionnaires se
parlent mais louis métivier est exaspéré
ça fait depuis 2008 qu'on a créé un
comité conjoint de ces québec fait des
efforts mais il ya trop de monde autour
de la table il ya aucune décision you
personnes tranche
c'est assez pour passer à l'action
acculée à la faillite
il cache mal sa frustration en évoquant
la richesse des propriétaires de site
d'enfouissement qui contrairement à lui
reçoivent de l'argent pour chaque donne
qu'il traite et ce sont des déchets ce
que je déplore le plus long c'est comme
une compagnie comme la nôtre qui me des
dizaines de millions de dollars à faire
un usine pour revaloriser de matières
premières nous n'arrivent pas survivre
quand les barreaux
d'évidence font des millions et 10
millions avec des sites d'enfouissement
avec deux bol puis des vannes qui
recueille puis ils font des millions
louis mitv espère maintenant que le
créancier accepteront de son plan de
relance
jean-sébastien rappelez-nous d'où vient
l'argent pour la collecte sélective
justement l'équipe croit en vertu de la
loi actuellement au québec
patrice toute l'opération de recyclage
est financé par l'entreprise privée
c'est-à-dire toutes les entreprises qui
mettent en marché soit des emballages
des imprimés des contenants elles
doivent verser ces entreprises là et on
avait 3000 en 2013 des redevances qui
passe par eco entreprises québec et
recyc québec en 2013 128 millions de
dollars de redevances ont été versés et
ensuite cet argent est distribué au sein
des municipalités mais donc ça amène
beaucoup de questions comme on l'a vu
dans le reportage est ce que cet argent
est vraiment utilisé pour le recyclage
pourquoi les entreprises comme recyc rpm
en bout de ligne en fontion ne touchent
pas l'argent pourquoi ça s'en va à
l'extérieur ce qui annule beaucoup de la
plus value écologique et de l'impact
économique du recyclage l'industrie
selon plusieurs est malade et en crée en
tout cas merci à jean sébastien et je
rejoins à gaspé benoît de villiers pdg
de recyc québec monsieur de villiers
bonsoir bonsoir
donc comment expliquer que des fleurons
québécois là c'est vraiment des il y
croit depuis deux générations recyc rpm
transforme plastique au québec sont en
faillite donc le système est en crise à
comment vous l'expliquez c'est sûr que
c'est une situation qui est préoccupant
de voir une entreprise comme earth etc
rpm dans une situation où elle est
aujourd'hui
comment on peut l'expliquer il on est
justement lorsqu'on parle du comité
conjoint dans le reportage que vous avez
montré juste avant on est en train de
revoir le film en état donc d'analyser
les flux monétaires pour s'assurer que
le système de compensation donc qui sert
à payer la collecte sélective et à payer
tout ce qui est la collecte le transport
et le tri soit optimal pour une enfant
qu'on se retrouve peut-être pendant les
situations comme on aujourd'hui
ok mais pour être clair là ça veut dire
que l'homme actuellement vous donner
l'argent municipalité pour qu'ils
ramassent bien sûr de façon sélective
les tous les produits il ya des centres
de tri qui sont financés par les
municipalités qui eux les centres de tri
vendent à des entreprises comme rpm
or au bout de la ligne au québec rpm le
reçoit pas un sou et exactement au
niveau de l'aide de skier à fond la
reddition de comptes confirme auprès des
municipalités c'est pour s'assurer que
effectivement les montants qui sont
rechargées aux producteurs qui sont
visés par la collecte sélective servent
à payer comme j'ai la collecte le
transport et le tri il faut voir qu'il
ya des matières comme la matière dont le
plastique de rpm qu'il ya un marché pour
ce lien marché au québec le prix moyen
était à 2 107 dollars par tonne
donc lorsqu'on dit que le marché est en
crise l'offre et la demande c'est quand
même son travail pour amener une valeur
aussi grande pour pour le plastique mais
pourquoi ils sont en faillite à la leur
si québec ingère pas dans le plan
d'affaires dans la gestion des
entreprises au niveau du conditionnement
lowey ce qu on est on est là pour
justement quand il ya un lien lien ne à
l'intérieur de la chaîne de des matières
recyclées on intervient
vous savez que le gouvernement a mis
déjà d'entendre dossier de rpm plus de 5
millions en prêts et prêts plus qu'à
d'un demi million en subventions pour
aider le jeu 6/4 pm à être l'amant garde
à être resté dans le marché et le porte
quelles raisons aujourd'hui ils sont là
ce nouveau de la gestion de l'entreprise
il faudrait voir mais monsieur de
villiers comme il y en a au québec
d'entreprise qui transforme prenons que
le plastique l'a5 si je crois un peu
moins de souvenirs de 3,4 qui transforme
le plastique puis je vous dirais que
pour avoir fait un sondage aujourd'hui
la vaste majorité du plastique est
encore transformé au québec on a perdu
rpm pour nous on ose espérer pour une
période très très très court terme mais
il ya encore de la demande au québec
pour le plastique
d'accord mais vous allez revoir
rapidement la façon dont l'argent
distribué parce que et je vous pose la
question très clairement l'argent qu'on
donne aux municipalités pour le
recyclage est ce qu'on est sûr que ça va
uniquement pour le recyclage je peux
vous assurer que la reddition de comptes
sert justement à cesser d'en demander de
recyc québec lorsque
on comptabilise laurent verron valide la
facturation que la municipalité a fait
pour la collecte sélective
que ce soit les coûts réels et les coûts
qui sont propres à ce point sur ce
projet là donc oui cette reddition les
ai fait et c'est justement ce qui nous
permet par la suite de travailler vécu
pour en favoriser la facture aux
producteurs on retient les l'expression
du monsieur qui disait de sa bosse je
vois les centres d'enfouissement devenir
millionnaire les propriétaires ils ont
enfoui avec un gros tracteur moi
j'essaie de transformer du plastique
depuis 20 ans et je me retrouve en
faillite il ya quelque chose de
paradoxal et je vous dirais que l'une
des solutions
ou est ce que le citoyen d'un fonds peut
avoir une grande grande valeur à
l'intérieur d'eux pourrait aider cette
économie là c'est justement dans le
faire le bon choix de ce qu'on met à
l'intérieur de la collecte sélective
parce que on a robot mettre en place les
meilleurs systèmes le récit québec à
financer pour améliorer les centres de
tri la qualité des matières qui sort à
l'extérieur de dans le fond à la fin du
processus des centres de tri mes
concitoyens vous misez sur la bonne
matière à l'intérieur du bac le jouet
est en plastique et ça va pas dans le
bac on va aider autant nos centres de
tri et on veut aider tous nos
conditionneurs du québec qui eux vont
recevoir une matière de purée de
meilleure qualité et on veut renvoyer
tout le monde
monsieur de villiers à vous étiez de
gaspé merci d'avoir fait le chemin chez
que j'avais fait de la route pour nous
alors merci à la prochaine on va suivre
ce dossier du recyclage parce que la
vitre dont nous ne pas parler le vert
qu'on enfouit actuellement merci à la
prochain que ça vous me dire au revoir